do you think we'll always have
war i think it goes to the fourth
question too so for example
um what do you do i mean we're
let's let's play with nation states now
although i don't know that nation states
are something we should think of as a
permanent construct forever
um but how is one nation-state supposed
to prevent another nation-state
from acting in ways that it would see as
either detrimental to the global
community or detrimental to the interest
of their own nation-state
um you know and i i think i think we've
had this question
of going back to ancient times but
certainly in the 20th century this has
come up quite a bit i mean
the whole second world war argument
sometimes revolves around the idea of
what the proper counterforce should be
uh can you create an entity a league of
nations a united nations
a one world entity maybe even that
that alleviates the need for
counterforce involving mass violence and
armies and navies and those things
i think that's an open discussion we're
still having
it's good to think through that because
um
having us like a united nations there's
usually a centralized control so there's
humans at the top
there's committees and uh usually like
leaders emerge a singular figures that
then can become corrupted by power and
it's just a really important
it feels like a really important thought
experiment and something to
really rigorously think through how can
you construct
systems of government that
are stable enough to push us towards
less and less war
and less and less unstable
and another tough word which is unfair
of application of force you know it's
that's really at the core of the
question that we're trying to figure out
as humans
as our weapons get better and better and
better destroying ourselves
it feels like it's important to think
about how we
minimize the over application
or unfair application of force there's
other elements that come into play too
you and i are discussing this at the
very high intellectual level of things
but there is also a tail wagging the dog
element to this so think of a society of
warriors
a tribal society from a long time ago
how much do the fact that you have
warriors in your society
and that their reason for existing what
they take pride in what they train for
um
what their status in their own
civilization how much does that
itself drive the responses of that
society right um
how much do you need war to legitimize
warriors
um you know that's the old argument that
you get to and we've had this in the
20th century too that
that the creation of arms and armies
creates
a an incentive to use them right and and
that they themselves can drive that
incentive as
as a justification for their reasons for
existence you know
um that's where we start to talk about
the interactivity of all these different
elements of society upon one another
so when we talk about you know
governments and war we need to take into
account
the various things those governments
have put into place in terms of systems
and armies and things like that
to to protect themselves right for
reasons we can all understand
but they exert a force on your your
range of choices
don't they
you